so today's draft big cat which remote
at-home draft setup would we most like
to be present for when the draft gets
rolling next thursday night i've got the
trivia question for you if you get it
right you get the first pick here we go
there were 47 trades involving picks in
the 2019 draft who is the only nfl team
to not do a single draft trade last year
boy this one's hard here's a hint they
also have yet to trade any picks in this
year's draft that's really not much of a
hint you're throwing a dart in the dark
on this one
this is impossible give me the division
at least
afc west
all right uh the chargers
yeah
that really doesn't count you shouldn't
get the [ __ ] what a pick
yeah one out of four one out of four
that's how you did the sat you just went
through one out of four and circled one
of the whichever abc or d caught your
fancy at the time you got lucky this
time go ahead take the pick
okay number one easy one we just talked
about him dave gettleman uh if you can
if we have the picture of him and his
home office set up where it looks like i
don't think he even knows that like how
a computer works or where the computer
should be or what's going on i don't
know if it's plugged in i would love to
see dave gentleman set up on draft night
he doesn't strike me as a computer guy
remember he hired the analytics team
this past year which was essentially
just the geek squad from best buy so i
would love to watch dave gettleman's
draft set up he's he seems i don't know
if you saw the quote mike but he said
that uh the worst part about this remote
stuff is he doesn't get to touch and uh
feel and smell these prospects so that
to me means that he's more of a like get
your hands on a guy than then sit at
home and hop into a zoom or an aim chat
so i'm gonna go dave get him in number
one
yeah that's not a bad pick i mean it's
gonna be a real challenge for him
because this definitely is not up his
alley and he would have had to have
gotten up to speed very quickly over the
past few weeks to get comfortable with
it for me though you left the best one
on the board if i'm gonna hang out all
night
all dr first night of the draft any
night of the draft any sliver of the
draft i want to hang out with jerry
jones i want to first of all because
wherever he is it's going to be nice
whether it's one of his houses whether
it's the bus whether it's his boat it's
going to be nice accommodations there
will be plenty of johnny walker blue
available and other refreshments and you
just get to hang out with jerry jones
and see how the sausage gets made uh for
good bad or otherwise
okay i'll tell you why that's a bad pick
jerry jones also doesn't strike me as a
guy who uh is computer savvy jerry jones
also strikes me as a guy when his
computer's not going to be working or
something goes wrong he's going to have
a meltdown i don't want to be around
jerry jones
why
i want to be around i i'm i'm because
last name because if my last name isn't
jones i'm probably getting fired
i was thinking that you were going to go
more with once he doesn't know what's
going on you actually get put to work
and you have to he expects you to figure
out how to work his computer kind of
like you know uh i remember when i got
my parents on microwave you know it it
sat there on this on the counter for two
years before uh they ever bothered to
figure out how to use it and that was
only after i showed them how to use it
how how old are you
old enough
old enough
to park i'm just thinking of the old
tech like you know you bought it in the
sears catalog in the 50s like oh look at
this technology microwave
no microwave slightly more recent than
that all right make your next pick we
don't have a whole lot of time here
because one of us has to leave early one
of us can't commit to the full show i
don't i don't have a uh the uh barn in
the in the office in west virginia i'm
stuck in a thousand square per uh square
foot apartment in brooklyn all right my
next book will be easy it's your your
coach mike i would love to watch mike
zimmer navigate this draft and navigate
technology because again i'm going for
pics where i don't think that they jive
with the newest technology and mike
zimmer doesn't really strike me as a guy
who spends a lot of time on the computer
i i wouldn't even i'd be hard-pressed to
find mike zimmer even having an email
address do you think he has one do you
think they finally made him get one
because they're like hey we're gonna
have to send you a link for this oh no
no he's he's he's savvy he's got a cell
phone and he texts trust me oh i've
definitely
trust me i've received some i've
received some hostile text messages from
time to time based upon the things that
i have said so yes
uh of off the record uh too late for
that but yes he's hey i think that that
having email is below knowing how to use
a phone and actually text on it don't
you i mean if you can actually send out
cognizant text messages on your phone
you've at least figured out the tech
game a little bit haven't you no i think
there's i know i disagree because i
think the email is like people just have
emails but they never use it because why
would you need it if you're a football
coach
all right uh if i were you this is where
i'd be saying i'm completely and totally
dominating the draft because how can you
leave bill belichick on the board
through two rounds this is the ultimate
opportunity to expose him as being a
complete liar when he talks about not
knowing anything about technology i
don't know what bookface is and snap
face and face chat and and then you see
him morph into
right stephen hawking when he has a
chance to get in front of this this wall
of computers and and he's he's mastering
every possible angle uh yeah i want to
be there when belichick has this code
cracked because you know
no matter what happens he's going to
have this thing mastered because that's
just who he is he's always going to
figure it out he's always going to find
an advantage
i mean i was i was going to say ernie
adams is probably bill gates and we just
don't know it yet so he you know ernie
adams probably has him all set up that's
why i'm not going with that pick because
he also it's not really exposing that he
knows about those things because we all
know he knows about those things and
he's just doing coach speak when he does
it um okay my last pick i'm gonna go
with i can't believe this is on the
board i want to see mike zimmer's draft
room i mean not mike zimmer mike
florio's draft room i'm getting my mice
confused i wanna always make that third
pick why do you always find a way to
make the third pick about me do you have
no other because you've been in the barn
i love the barn so let's get a live
webcam to go to your draft room to your
war room and see what's going on see
what's cooking and uh let's see maybe we
can catch you i know how big of a family
you have maybe we can catch you in a dak
prescott situation
[Laughter]
trust me that has not happened we have
fully complied with all stay-at-home
orders all cdc guidelines uh and uh yeah
it'll just be me and my son in the barn
and i don't have any draft picks if you
haven't heard i've yet to trade into
round one so i don't know why you think
that would be interesting you left on
the board so many guys i got to go andy
reed i thought that's where you were
going how would you not want to be with
andy reid for the same reason you want
to be with jerry jones because johnny
walker blew you want to be with andy
reid because the spread is going to be
unmatched
it's true the spread's going to be
unmatched um i also
i saw andy read that picture of him with
his computer and reed actually seems
like he uh someone who who knows his way
around a computer so i i don't think i
think he'll actually be competent in
this i i don't think you'll have the
comedy of errors you know who's a a
sneaky one mike before i go vic fangio's
another one vic fangio watching vic
fangio and john elway trying to navigate
the draft would be very very funny
couple that i had on the board bill
o'brien just because nobody quite knows
what he's doing is the gm
he's a good yeah he's a good yeah quite
possibly uh chris greer just because the
dolphins have three first-round picks i
think the level of activity that night
is going to be worth the price of
admission and then i got to mention tom
telesco the chargers gm because peter
king had a photo in football morning of
america of tom telesco's house
i tell you what of all the jobs in
sports being the chargers gm must pay
the best because that place is a palace
that's where i want to hang out on draft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports